plus loin tout de suite avec vous
Antoine Mariotti bonjour Antoine en ce
début d'année on le voit bien les les
ruches ne les Russes ne relâchent pas la
pression on l'a vu avec ses
bombardements toute la limite hier et ça
recommence de nouveaux ce matin oui il y
a eu 39 drones vous l'avez dit qu'on
était interceptés cette nuit par les
forces ukrainiennes il y en a eu 45 la
nuit précédente la nuit du jour de l'an
arrêtez avec les ruches parce que ça
fait difficile mais en effet ça a été un
jour de l'an particulièrement
violent très symbolique d'ailleurs parce
qu'il y a énormément des dizaines de
bombardements et de drones de drone
kamikaze ces fameux drone shades qui
sont de fabrication
iranienne et que d'ailleurs les Russes
ont rebaptisés géranium il nous donne
presque un côté poétique à quelque chose
d'aussi violent et donc plusieurs
dizaines qui ont été interceptés et
certains ont été tirés seulement
quelques minutes après les douze coups
de minuit et on va le voir à l'antenne
dans quelques instants sur une photo qui
a été postée sur le compte Facebook et
bien du chef de la police de Kiev André
inhibitov et vous voyez ce sont les
débris d'un de ces drones qui sont
arrivés eux n'ont pas sur la ligne de
front comme ils le précise mais akief la
capitale loin de la ligne de front et
c'est les inscriptions que vous voyez
ici ici bien c'est tout simplement écrit
bonne année en russe avec un feutre
comme vous pouvez le voir par un soldat
russe on voulait se juger du bon goût
mais en tout cas le message est très
clair c'est soldats nous disent voilà on
ne va pas s'arrêter là et même si ça a
été difficile pour l'armée russe depuis
l'été dernier depuis la le début la
contre-offensive massive ukrainienne est
bien fin août et bien les Russes n'ont
pas du tout l'intention de lâcher bien
au contraire puisque le ministre russe
de la Défense ergame promis une victoire
absolue alors ces vagues de drone les
Russes affirment quels sont contre des
objectifs
terroristes que c'est contre des usines
de fabrication de drones les Ukrainiens
évidemment c'est propagande contre
propagande dit c'est uniquement contre
des infrastructures infrastructures clés
et on a eu des coupures de courant de
chauffage bon il y a aussi un espèce
d'entre-deux c'est à dire qu'il y a des
cils qui ne sont ni menaçantes pour pour
la Russie ni clé mais qui sont par
exemple bien un hôtel de Kiev qui a été
éventré ce weekend
le 24 février prochain marquera les 1 an
du début de cette guerre quelle
perspective pour pour l'Ukraine est-ce
qu'on a est-ce qu'on a un début de
réponse on parle d'une éventuelle
contre-offensive heureuse qui pourra
intervenir dans les dans les semaines
qui arrivent oui ce qui est certain en
tout cas il est très dur de faire des
prévisions dans ce conflit mais c'est
que pour l'instant on ne voit toujours
pas la lumière au bout du tunnel
décidément mais l'année 2023 s'annonce
extrêmement compliqué et elle va être
compliqué pour les Ukrainiens parce
qu'il faut arriver et bien consolider
les avancées militaires faites depuis
l'été dernier qu'on arrivait aussi à
continuer à progresser pour mettre la
Russie dos au mur les forcer peut-être
et bien à reculer voir quitter
complètement l'Ukraine silici arrive
mais un autre défi aussi pour les
Ukrainiens c'est de continuer à avoir le
soutien des occidentaux notamment en
armes c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
volodime qui est sorti pour la première
fois du pays il y a quelques semaines
pour aller à Washington parce qu'on voit
bien cette carte qui est juste derrière
moi avec les zones en bleu ce sont les
zones de principal contre-offensive
ukrainienne alors que ces zones et bien
vous voyez en rouge sont détenus sont
tenues par la Russie celles qui sont
cernés de noir ici ici étaient déjà sous
contrôle russe avant la guerre et donc
depuis 2014 mais donc les les Ukrainiens
continuent à avancer mais ils ont besoin
pour ça de l'armement
occidentale et l'aide en renseignement
grâce au satellites notamment ne pose
pas de problème en revanche on voit bien
que cette aide occidentale ça coûtait
énormément d'argent fournir des canons
des chars etc ça coûte énormément
d'argent et aux États-Unis par exemple
il y a des voies républicaines au
Congrès qui commence à dire il faut
arrêter il faut arrêter de soutenir
l'Ukraine mais il y a aussi des
complications côté russes on parle en
effet d'une nouvelle offensive ou contre
contre-offensive russe dans les semaines
qui viennent mais on parle aussi d'une
potentielle nouvelle de 500 à 700 000
hommes même selon certaines rumeurs qui
ne sont absolument pas vérifiées pour
l'instant on attend de voir sont
notamment des renseignements
Ukrainiens mais pour cela il faut aussi
pouvoir fournir suffisamment de
munitions et Vladimir Poutine que l'on
voit l'antenne à mis la pression sur les
industriels russes on leur disant qu'il
fallait redoubler d'efforts produire
beaucoup plus et bien d'armement pour
pour l'armée russe justement parce que
il y a des difficultés en homme on le
voit bien mais aussi énormément et d'un
côté comme de l'autre il va falloir
réussir à tenir donc malheureusement on
voit bien que pour l'instant s'il y a un
grand absent tout ça c'est c'est la
diplomatie et une solution diplomatique
et pour l'instant complètement sur le
bas-côté merci beaucoup Antoine pour le
décryptage